hello everyone and welcome back to the
world rabbit championship it's a really
wild game from round nine a lot of you
have suggested it and for very good
reasons and like the title suggests you
will be unable to to decide who wins
this game until you see the entire game
and again it's one of the reasons why
it's so important to use hashtag
suggestion without you suggesting it I
would never have seen it and well I
imagine most of you wouldn't either
so without further ado young crystal
doodle vs. Alex a fear of do the
exciting player with both white and
black pieces and Alex a fear of pretty
much more modern day 12 this game can
only be only be a good one
and the only way I imagine this game
could be more violent if Shiro had the
white pieces but then again do that is
is you know we're always going all out
with the black pieces so I don't think I
would be it would be any any less
attractive so without further ado let's
check it out Duda opens with c4 the
English is on the board and we have c60
replies with he's going for the
caro-kann set up against the English we
have night of three d5 striking in the
center we have III Knight to f6 and now
Knight to c3
we have Knight bt7 preparing e5 and now
Queen to c2 we have E 5 by shear of and
now comes C captures on d5 we have
Knight captures on d5 you cannot improve
with seek a person d5 because Knight b5
is just super annoying
there's no no good way to deal with this
you could block it but then b4 is just
very strong and while you can continue
playing this with something like this
why it will just be up upon so no reason
to do something like this so if 0 goes
to night capture Sun d5 and Bishop the
c4 now threatening and d5 we have night
before attacking dudas Queen and here
quinta efore
there is a known game where Queen to be
one was played it was also from the
world rabbit championship but last year
a very good opening
versus Nikita with YouGov and the
opening was able to win the game after
Queen to be won but do this is if I can
centralize my queen why shouldn't I and
okay you're threatening to pick up the
e5 pawn so we have Bishop to d6 shear of
defends it and
both players just castle with castles
castles and Duda now strikes in the
center we have d4 we looked at e8 Bashir
of putting a rook on the same file as
the Queen and now a three pushing the
knight back so before reacting to this
Knight to f6 pushing the Queen to eat
either back to be one or to a different
square that do that chooses h4 and now
comes a capture Sundy for first
attacking the c3 Knight e4 looks it
looks interesting it keeps the central
closed frees the bishop problem is after
Knight to g5 you will lose the pawn and
ID f7 is under attack and also the three
the two knights and the Queen attack d
4e for points so once you defend on f7
let's say Knight here you block the
bishop then you just lose d4 pawn so she
decides to trade it
he captures on d4 we have a capture Sun
before and now as the knight is still
under attack Knight bd5 Bishop to d3 do
the now switches over to this diagonal
we have h6 fear of the great attacker
himself you know has a very developed
spidey sense so he always sends his
danger and the bishop to d2 continuing
development connecting rooks and here we
have Knight captures on c3 we have B
characters on c3 Bishop captures looks
interesting if you could ever open up
this diagonal but it's very unlikely
that you will play d5 maybe as a pawn
sacrifice but not really most likely
this Bishop will just remain a pawn for
for quite some time so after this we
have B captures on c3 and now Bishop to
g4 continuing development threatening to
mess up do this bone structure in front
of the King Duda says that's not a
problem he continues with a for now the
pawn will no longer be a target you can
start developing the rook and shear of
says okay we're busting open the Kings
side with the shop captures on f3 g
captures and now Knight to d5 with ideas
of bringing the Queen into the game well
first offering the Queen trade but do
the declines is we have Queen Chi for
introducing the threat of Bishop
captures on h6 since the Jeep on would
be pinned now and Queen to f6 developing
and dealing with the
now rook a to be one I'm going after the
Beast some important but Shiro goes
Bishop to f4 he attacks well the
defender of the c3 pawn so here Duda has
to make a decision whether he wants to
trade everything let's say with
something like captures Knight captures
and the Queen f5 going after Queen h7
here you would you would be forced to
trade but then Black has 90 to check the
c3 pawn is under attack and okay you
will have to deal with this threat would
be six but all in all black is black is
doing very well here he has two point
islands of white has four point islands
white has doubled F pawns so black would
be better here so instead Duda goes for
c-4 now he attacks the defender of the
bishop on f4 we have a trade here Bishop
captures we have C captors on d5 and now
rook eight d8 activity above all after
all we have D captures on c6 by Duda and
rook captures on d4 attacking the Queen
and the bishop on d3 Bishop T you could
go Queen f5 again offering your Queen
trade and if Queen captures then he just
capture with the bishop get rid of this
threat but Duda doesn't want a Queen
trade he just goes Bishop to e4 now both
of the threats have been eliminated we
have B captures on c6
grabbing upon and rook the b7 do the now
brings rook to the seventh rank now and
attacks the the a7 point which would
create a nice past a pawn for him and
here best way for sheriff to continue
this game is g6 you give up the pawn you
push h5 you kick away the Queen there
are no good threats on the King side and
then you just continue playing this game
as you are better White's pawn structure
in front of the King is all messed up
and you have very active pieces however
here sheriff played a move that is well
unexplainable for a player of his his
caliber but then again they don't call
him modern-day tau for no reason here
here of play the rook captures on a4 and
well feel free to pause the video and
try to figure out why this this sort of
doesn't work while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations
sporting a fairly simple tactic and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show Bishop to h7 check and now you just
open up and attack towards the rook so
shear of captures do that captures the
rook on a4 and now a sheet of the Mad
Men sacrifices yet another piece he
plays Queen captures on f3 and yes this
introduces some very nasty ideas like
rookie 4 followed by rook g4 mate but
Duda has something to say about this do
the plays Queen to c2 check
we have f5 blocking check and now again
do the Hester I decide what to do here
before capturing the best of you should
really play rook to b3 but both players
are very low on time and do that grabs
the bishop so now do that is up a whole
rook the problem is he's completely lost
now so feel free to pause the video and
try to find a winning idea for shear off
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those who were able to do it
congratulations on finding the the best
the absolute best maneuver for black and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's rook to e6 it's not rook
the rook to e4 if you play this then
white has h4 and you don't have work to
g4 that's the problem you do have it but
it only yields a draw because you have
to go for this repetition check and then
you will use this diagonal to keep
checking and the white king so it will
be a draw by repetition of moves so rook
the e6 was played by Shiro now rook the
g6 is deadly and here you don't have you
don't have all that many good options
best for white is to sacrifice the rook
on g7 and give up your you being a rock
up then go Queen d4 check and then
riemann over your pieces to somehow stop
the attack but still you will be down
two points so that doesn't really help
you do the however played rook the c1
he's trying to give his King an escape
route however this doesn't work so once
again feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for a
sheared off while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations it's
actually a forced mate in seven and for
those who just want to enjoy the enjoy
the show it's Queen to g4 check hero did
not play Queen to g4 check
she replayed rooked g6 check right away
but we'll get to that Quinta g4 check
first is essential because you want to
keep your rook here guarding the e1
square you don't want to allow the White
King to escape problem is if you go King
f1 now then you have Queen h3 check you
force the King back and now after look
the g6 now is just over if the King
moves
Queen Queen here is made so you're just
gonna have to give up the Queen captures
you move the review move the King and
this will be made so after Queen g4
check you have to go to h1 but now rook
g6 is a completely different story there
is no defense against a queen g2 mate
even if you prevent it with something
like this the the guard this squared
then is just Queen f3 check you have to
block and then Queen captures and g2 is
mate
so should have played instead of Queen
g40 played rook to g6 check and now it's
still good it's still winning for black
however you have to play it extremely
precisely King f1 was played Shirov went
for Queen to h1 check King 2 e 2 and now
Queen to rook the e6 check so you cannot
spare a moment here you are down the
rook so you either have to win some
serious material or checkmate the white
king we have King to d3 by Judah and now
once again perhaps for the last time in
this video pause the video and try to
find the winning move for sure of while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and finding the only
move that wins and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show its Queen to
f3 with check and now whatever white
place it's over if you go King C to rock
the d2 wins the Queen and yes it's 2
rooks against the Queen but it's an open
board and the black is just up 3 points
so this will be completely winning on
the other hand after Queen f3 chug you
might consider some other ideas like
King before but then just rook d6 check
again we'll pick up the Queen and you
don't really have all that many other
options if you go King to c4 then you
just March the the white king of the
board rook to e4 checking c5 Queen a3
check you have to go up the board and
now Queen the a6 check will pick up the
rook if you go up then just rook here
so you win it that way and if you
the board doesn't really matter Menke
after-sun b7 you've grabbed the rook and
now again you were up two points and
most likely you will check made the
white king so Queen to f3 you all found
it congratulations however sheriff in
the heat of battle played rook to d6
right away yes you are winning the Queen
but not really because your queen is
under attack as well so Queen to f3 was
actually a safety move so what do you do
here
well King the c3 was played and now only
now hero plays Queen f3 check but now
why do that is able to block a queen and
block check and get the Queen out of
harm's way so now do that is up a hole
rook and the fear of doesn't have made
then do that is just upper rook so what
what can still happen here we have Queen
to d5 by sheriff and now rook the g1 by
Judah going after the the g7 pawn queen
a5 check with King 2b 3 and now Queen to
d5 check we have King Tubby to and now
rook the d7 getting rid of one of the
rooks so here of course do the trades he
he will be up a whole rook but then then
again the White King is on an open board
perhaps sheriff Ken can keep the king in
check forever we have rook captures
Queen captures and now rook the a1 going
after rook captures on a 7 so here we
have c5 by sheer of preventing this
giving up the c5 pawn but then you will
be able to start checking the white king
do that except that we have Queen
captures on c5 and now Queen d2 check we
have King b3 Queen d3 check we have King
2b for now Queen back to d2 check King
to a4 we have Queen to f4 with check
King goes up the board King gave 5 we
have Queen to d2 check King gay sex
Queen to d3 check and here Duda just
grabs the pawn king capture Sunday 7 and
sheriff goes all over again Queen d7
check King ace X we have Queen to d3
with check King a5 now Queen to d2 with
check King to a4 and Queen to f4 check
we have King to a 3 and now Queen to f3
check and here finally do the blocks to
check with Queen to e3 Queen back the a
8 with check King to be 2 and now
be a check we have Quinta see - and here
do the graph Sheeran grabs the h2 pawn
we've worked a five now creating a set
up that will eliminate the f5 pawn with
check so what can she do here he
continues Queen c7 check we have Queen
to c5 and well it was in this position
on more fifty-six that Alexei she
resigned the game after after this
incredible roller coaster where he had a
winning winning combination for so many
moves like he even had a foursome
eighteen seven but that's just how wild
chess is anything can happen and you you
can never know who wins the game
sometimes you have a pretty good idea
who's gonna win but not in this game so
here he resigns because once you move
the Queen wherever you move it you're
gonna lose this pawn with check and
whatever you do if you move the King or
block with g6 doesn't really matter the
Queen simply moves and the next you will
block any checks fall followed by rock
c7 check the queen guards the c7 square
and well either win the black queen or
or checkmate the black king so after
Queen to c5 she resigned and a brilliant
victory for heung-soo stuff Duda and you
can see how much he he likes walking on
the edge he was on the verge of defeat
for for the entire game and then came
out on top really incredible stuff so we
mentioned that we're gonna show the
standings now that we have them so here
are the standings after ten rounds of
the world rapid championship let's let's
check him out so there we have it ranked
after round 10 first place only one with
eight points it's Magnus Carlsen six
wins and four draws no losses incredible
stuff and the two other times the when
Magnus had eight out of ten in in a
world rapid championship he won first
place so he definitely is in a good
position to do so this year followed by
seven and a half points among how young
she stole Duda and maxime beaugeois
graph
maxime faces Magnus Carlsen today in
round 11 and I do believe on how faces
do I don't think they played yet so with
seven points
shocker mama DRV on Deponia Sheila Kwang
Liam a linear Dominguez Agadir Hussein
of Hikaru Nakamura 11 Erin and Peter
Svidler Sergey Kerrigan and
Meiri under 18 and also david Antoni
Haro with six and a half points
Ilyas myrin Boris grachev Alexander
motive Paco Vallejo onigiri Alexandre
Rahman of Pavel Punk rat of Alexei Draya
Parvati a group of the kneeled above and
Alexander Grisha
so those are the top 26 I usually show
25 but I saw Grisha was on 26 so I
showed the first 26 you know just to
include to include Sasha
so yeah yeah once again I do hope you
enjoyed it and you know congratulations
if you were able to spot who who will
win this game you know once again I
would like to thank Michael Carey Pete
spawn robos Victor Klein David gross
skinned and preserved Oh for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
feed a blitz and rap championship for
the next three days so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day